[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So welcome everyone.
Thank you so much for coming
to The Teaching Kitchen
today for "Food Talks."
So today we have a
very special guest.
Michelle McKenzie's here to
talk about her brand new book,
"Dandelion & Quince,"
her first one.
Do you want to speak a little
bit about yourself before we
get started with the demo?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Sure.
So I am working on my
second cookbook now.
This one actually came
out almost a year ago now.
I'm in the process of working
on my second cookbook.
But before I got into
food and cooking,
I was actually a nutrition
and biochemistry major
at UNC Chapel Hill
studying fat enzymes,
and was really fascinated
with food and healing
and how food really
affects the body.
And so I went to culinary
school in New York City,
and went to a
school that actually
specialized a little
bit in food and healing.
They taught you
French technique,
but they also taught about
Chinese medicine and Ayurveda
and the Eastern
view of nutrition--
after I got the Western view.
And I still thought I was
going back to school to do--
I had taken MCATs.
I thought I was going
to go do either research
or go to med school.
And then I worked at this
amazing restaurant in New York
and just never looked back.
And worked in restaurants
for many years,
became a private chef.
And then I started
teaching people
at a place called the Cancer
Wellness Center in Atlanta
and fell in love with teaching.
And I've been teaching in
some capacity ever since.
And I just left my full-time
job recently as the Director
of a culinary school
in San Francisco
to work full time
on my second book.
I wrote this book while running
a cooking school and teaching.
SPEAKER: That's impressive.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: And I
don't want to do that again.
I did it, and I felt
like Superwoman,
and then I fell apart and put
myself back together again.
And now I'm going to keep
it a little bit more sane
this time around.
But yeah, I'm excited to
talk to you about this book.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
Well, what are you
cooking for us today?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: So we're
making two seasonal recipes,
two things that happen to be--
these are recipes
that are really
great for the
transition from summer
to fall, which
we're in right now.
And we also picked two
that are vegetarian--
actually, vegan.
Well, except for some Feta.
And you can leave that off
if you don't want cheese.
So the first one we're doing
is a watermelon and cucumber
salad.
And I'm going to show
you the photo in the book
because the original recipe
is in the sprouts chapter.
And it's on page 241, if
you guys want to look.
And so we're not
using sprouts today,
because there is a little bit
of concern about sprouts--
that they're not
handled really well.
If you buy sprouts from a
farmer's market, freshly
sprouted, or you sprout them at
home, they're perfectly safe.
But today we're
using watercress,
which I mention in the
recipe as a good substitute.
And watercress is also a
bit of an unsung vegetable.
It has kind of a peppery bite
that some people don't like.
But if you find ways
to balance that peppery
bite to complement it--
for instance, with something
sweet like watermelon--
it's really palatable.
And watercress is a
powerhouse of a green,
just full of a lot of nutrients
that are really good for us.
So I just wanted you guys to
see the beautiful buckwheat
sprouts, because
they're so pretty.
And buckwheat sprouts
are also incredibly
high in calcium and lots of
other good things for you.
So if you can find
those, seek them out.
And they have these
beautiful, pink stems
that look really lovely
next to the watermelon.
So that's the first
thing we're going to do.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
And then the second
recipe we're going to do
is basically a vegan taco.
So it has beans and
has collard greens,
and the collard greens give
it an additional meatiness.
And they cooked some
collard greens in advance.
They taste amazing.
And collard greens-- again,
I grew up in the South,
and I ate collard greens and
corn bread for breakfast.
That cornbread was
fried in bacon fat.
It was not vegan.
But I love the combination
of corn and collard greens
together.
I think they just
go really well.
So I thought about the
collard green taco.
And we're going to make
the unsung vegetable--
in addition to collard greens--
that we're using
in that recipe, is
the tomatillo, which has
its own chapter in the book.
So I'll talk a little bit about
that when I get over there.
So yeah, that's what
we're going to do today.
SPEAKER: That's great.
So as she's cooking,
you guys are more than
welcome to ask questions.
It's a little funky, so--
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
I love questions.
SPEAKER: Yes.
That's a great.
So I'm just going to repeat
them back into the mic
so that those on the
livestream can hear us.
Should we get started?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Yeah, let's get started.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: So I'm going
to start with the watermelon
and cucumber salad.
And a lot of people
don't know this,
but melons and cucumber
are in the same family,
and they go really
well together.
And if you actually get
some heirloom melons
and some heirloom
cucumbers, you can see
the resemblance between them.
Has anyone ever seen those
little lemon cucumbers?
They're round.
They look a little bit
like a little melon.
So they're in the same family.
They go really,
really well together.
So for the taste that you're
getting today, you're getting--
we cut up the
watermelon really small.
But I'm going to show
you how I'd plate this
if it was for an
elegant dinner and this
was a family-style platter.
So I take half a watermelon,
and I peel it with a knife--
sort of like you
would peel an orange
that you were going to supreme.
And I just run my
knife along the rind.
This is just an easy
way to get in there.
And because we're going to
cut this into almost shards--
1/4 inch shards-- you don't
have to cut in a round way.
You can just get this
peel straight off.
And this is great, because
it's a seedless watermelon.
It should make it really easy.
And then what we're
going to do is
cut the watermelon
and the cucumber
into similar-sized pieces.
And like I said,
the watermelon--
a lot of people--
raise your hand if you've had
watermelon in a savory dish.
Savory.
Oh, lots of people, great.
It goes really well with cheese.
SPEAKER: What doesn't?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
And people grill it.
What do you guys--
how have you had it?
What doesn't go with cheese?
It's true.
I know.
So I'm going to take this guy.
So I start out 1/4--
maybe somewhere between
1/4 and 1/2 inch slices.
It also goes really
well with vinegar.
And again, that's about balance.
You have sweet watermelon,
so something peppery or spicy
and then something acidic.
Acid balances sweet.
And when you want a full--
especially for a savory dish,
you want that acid in there.
I like acid even in my desserts.
But I'm a huge fan of acid, so
I'm a weird one in that way.
I don't like things
to look too perfect.
I like them to look a
little bit haphazard.
So I'm going to cut
those into triangles--
this.
And then the cucumber
we're using today--
this is just a regular cucumber.
If you can get those
cucumbers that have--
they almost look like snakes.
I don't know, they're showing
up at farmer's markets.
I think more and more
farmers are growing them.
I've even seen them at Whole
Foods and some grocery stores.
Those are a Middle
Eastern style.
They're called
Armenian cucumbers.
You'll see them called
Persian cucumbers.
There's several different
varieties in there.
And they have practically
no bitterness.
So you don't have to peel them.
You don't have to seed them.
They're amazing.
If you can find those,
they're incredibly good.
So same thing with the cucumber.
Maybe we'll just do some slices.
And if you're going to cook
a lot of vegetables at home,
something I say in the
beginning of the book--
and this is true,
really, across the board,
but especially if you want to
do a lot of vegetable cooking--
your best friend is
a big cutting board
and a sharp knife.
You will hate cooking vegetables
if you have a small cutting
board and a dull knife.
It's like if you had a
desk here that was crammed
and your computer was
slow and you had paper
stacked up all over the place.
You would hate your job, no
matter how much you actually
loved the content of your job.
And vegetables are the same way.
You can't do a lot of
chopping if the cutting
board's really small.
It's just incredibly
frustrating.
I'd have to keep moving stuff
off the board as I went.
And this is a good one-- a
nice, big, wooden cutting board.
So I'm going to do one
more little cucumber here.
All right, so this is an
incredibly fast salad.
Fall produce is my favorite.
I feel bad saying that.
I shouldn't.
I wrote a book on
vegetables for year round,
but it's my favorite.
But summer is great,
because it's easy.
You barely have to do
anything to it or cook it.
So right before
I plate this, I'm
want to talk about
these little guys.
So I have a recipe in the
book for pickled shallots.
So shallots are typically
used-- this is a peeled shallot.
It's the allium family, so
they're related to onions.
But they have a much more mild
flavor, a little bit sweeter.
And they're typically used
in sauces and vinaigrettes.
That's how most people see them.
But in other parts of the world,
they use them very differently.
They're pickled
often, and they're
fried until they get crispy.
And I also have a recipe--
shallots have their own chapter
in the book.
That's how much I
love these things.
And I think even though people
know what a shallot is, they
do one or two things
with it, and then
they don't know what
else to do with it.
So to give shallot
more of a chance,
to show off what it can do.
And when you fry shallots--
even though that's not
what we're doing, I
have to put in a plug
for the fried shallots-- and you
do them, it's a weird method.
It's a slow fry.
And when you do a
slow fry on them,
it takes about 20 minutes.
They stay crispy for a few days.
You can just put
them in a little pint
container like this, cap
it at room temperature,
and they stay crispy.
And you can just top
salads, grains, eggs,
whatever with them.
They're addictive.
But these are the
pickled shallots,
and they've been
sitting in red wine
vinegar and a little bit of
salt for some period of time.
I mean, even if you just
do this for 5 minutes,
it makes a difference.
It takes the bite
off the shallot,
and the shallot
infuses the vinegar.
So then you have your garnish,
which is the sliced shallot,
and you also have
shallot vinegar.
So next time you go to make a--
and when I do this, I usually
make 1/2 cup portion.
So next time you go to
make a salad dressing,
you don't need to
dice a shallot.
You have shallot
vinegar already made.
In this case, we're going to
use both the pickled shallot
and the shallot vinegar
in this dressing.
So just wanted to
talk about that.
The other components of
the salad-- so cucumber,
watermelon, pickled shallot.
We have some cilantro.
We're using a lot of cilantro.
Do I have any
cilantro haters today?
We can leave some cilantro--
I know-- OK, 1, 2, 3.
So we need three tacos and
salads without any cilantro.
I encourage the
cilantro haters, though,
to try these cilantro
flowers, though, I picked up
this morning, because--
so cilantro is in
the coriander family.
And has anyone had
coriander seed, the spice?
It tastes different than the
green part of the plant, right?
And when cilantro bolts--
that's what happened.
So this used to look like this.
And then cut late
in the season when
the plant's been in the
ground for a long time,
it bolts and it forms
seeds and flowers.
It's all edible.
That whole thing is edible.
I use the stems like a bayleaf
when I'm braising something.
And I use the flowers
and the seeds as garnish,
and they have a totally
different flavor.
So maybe when you go--
no pressure, but maybe try it.
And farmers are
now selling these.
So again, another chapter in
the book is flowering herbs--
bolted herbs.
And I see people go by these
things of dill blossoms
and cilantro blossoms and
they just keep walking.
They're like, those are
beautiful, what are those?
And the guy's like,
they're dill flowers.
And they're like, wow.
And then they don't
buy them, or don't
know what to do with them.
So I was like, they're getting
their whole chapter, too.
And then some sumac.
Sumac is a berry.
And because this has some Feta--
and we've got the watermelon
and the cucumber--
sumac is a wonderful,
another bright element.
It tastes a little
bit like lemon,
and it's really beautiful
on top of the watermelon.
And this is used a lot in
Middle Eastern cooking,
and I encourage you
to seek this out.
My next book is on the modern
larder, so something like sumac
will get featured extensively.
It's the unsung pantry
ingredients, really.
I had my unsung
vegetable heroes,
and now I'm doing the pantry.
And then some toasted
pine nuts, which
aren't listed in the recipe,
but they're in the photo.
They're not necessary, but they
add a nice, crunchy element.
So we have our acid, which
is a nice contrast in flavor
to the sweet watermelon.
And the pine nuts,
or you could use--
pistachios would be really
good-- are a nice contrast
and texture to the
rest of the salad.
So when I talk about
plating salads,
I find this to be a really--
maybe you guys are savvy cooks.
But when I was teaching in
San Francisco, over and over
again people had never learned
how to compose a salad.
Most people know how to
toss gently with your hands.
They've seen that on TV.
I rarely toss a salad.
Almost never.
There's a few salads I toss.
If I just want a
simple green salad
to go with some sort
of braised meat dish,
then I'll just toss that salad
in a simple lemon vinaigrette.
But most of my salads I compose.
And that is because I want
the flavor elements to stay
a little bit
separate, and I don't
want things to get mashed.
For instance, something
like cheese or something
like avocado or
something like beet--
there's just so many things
that when you mix them,
they get all over the place.
And I don't want that.
But mostly, I compose
because it's pretty
and because when you're
eating the salad,
each bite is different.
Sumac's not in every
single bite that you get.
The pickled shallot isn't in
every single bite that you get.
So what I would do
here is I would do--
and like I said, I like to
do a haphazard, asymmetrical
layering thing.
So a little bit of watermelon,
a little bit of cucumber.
And then the pickled
shallot I like
to do right on top of the--
scattered on top of the
watermelon a little bit.
And this is a good salad.
It can sit for a little bit.
It's going to sit
while I make the tacos.
SPEAKER: I was going
to say, though,
seems like a really
good salad that you
could pre-make and
bring to a house
party, dinner party or
something like that.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Yeah, I
would pre-make all the elements
and put them--
go to a restaurant supply
store and buy quart and pint
containers.
I don't use Tupperware at
home, because these are great.
They stack great in the fridge.
I would put all the
elements in here,
and then yeah, you could
just quickly compose it.
This is the watercress
that I mentioned earlier.
So let's see.
Let's do some watercress.
Who's had watercress?
Do you like it?
Keep your hand up
if you like it.
Great, you guys are good eaters.
SPEAKER: Success.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I know.
Got the right audience today.
A little bit of
cilantro-- and I'm
a huge fan of mint
in this salad.
So if you like mint, or if
you don't think you like mint
but you want to try it, this is
a great salad to try that with.
A little bit of cheese.
Let's see if I can use a spoon.
And this is crumbled Feta.
I really like the Feta, too,
that you can buy in a block.
So because this is crumbled,
instead of getting it
all over the place-- because
if you had it in the block,
I'd cut it like I
cut the watermelon.
And so it would stay separate.
And so instead of taking
this crumbled Feta
and putting it all over,
I'm going to just spoon it
into little portions
around, and as people
were serving themselves
off a big platter,
they would get some Feta.
But not everything is like
blanketed and white, salty
Feta.
Feta's my favorite
cheese, by the way.
Especially summer-- it goes
so well with summer stuff.
OK, so some Feta.
Some pine nuts.
AUDIENCE: Where do you
source your pine nuts?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
That's a good question.
If you're going
to buy pine nuts,
they go rancid really quickly.
So just find a place near
you that has high turnover--
usually a co-op market type
thing that has a bulk section.
The best pine nuts I have are
vacuum-packed in a freezer
somewhere, but I find very
few grocery stores do that.
Maybe online-- if
anyone has a good source
for some good pine
nuts, let me know.
I actually don't
think they're that
easy to find-- some good ones.
All right, do I have everything?
So I'm going to
basically just compose
a really quick vinaigrette.
So quick.
It's just a little bit
of shallot vinegar.
And I'm going to put
salt in the vinegar.
I hope I don't have any people
who are offended by this.
And I'm also going to
salt the watermelon
with some coarse salt.
So I put fine salt
in the vinegar,
which is dissolving
right now as it sits here.
And then some coarse salt on top
of the watermelon and cucumber.
And then I'm going to
take some olive oil--
and when you're
making vinaigrettes,
it's just a ratio.
So you don't really need to
think about it or measure it.
It's 1 part acid to 3 parts oil.
So you can just eye it.
Sometimes it's 1 to 2,
but usually it's 1 to 3
is what tastes best
to most people.
And then I'm just going to spoon
this around-- so no tossing.
And then I'm going to
just quickly do one layer.
And as I do that, does
anyone have any questions
about anything I've said?
I'm going to do one
more layer on top.
Not even a complete
layer, a half layer.
Any questions?
No?
I'm just going to
keep talking, then.
AUDIENCE: So I was thinking
about these blossoms,
because they have this
lovely, peppery aftertaste.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Would you steep them
in something, maybe an oil
or a vinegar, [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Any herb or blossom
you can steep into vinegar.
The cream's a great idea.
I assume you know this
since you're asking,
but if you just take something
and put it in cold cream
overnight, because of
cream's fat content,
it will absorb the flavor.
So let's say that you wanted
to make a lavender panna cotta,
you could just take lavender and
put it in cold cream over night
and use that cream to make
panna cotta the next day.
You'd have lavender panna cotta
or creme brulee or whatever.
So I imagine, yeah,
it would work.
But I mean, they're so--
I buy a bunch and just keep
it on my chopping block.
And I go through it so quickly.
I've never had any leftover to
try anything unusual with it.
But yeah, I imagine you could.
I've been trying to eat
a lot of protein lately,
and so one of my breakfasts
has been refried black beans
with two eggs and tortillas.
And just tons of
cilantro flowers
to just lighten it
up a little bit--
to attempt to lighten
it up a little bit.
All right, some more--
I'm going to go heavier
on the watercress here.
Can you guys all see this?
Can you see this where it is?
And on the fancy TV situation?
SPEAKER: If we move it to the--
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Yeah,
I want you guys to be
able to see what I'm doing.
I should have asked.
SPEAKER: Oh, this one
in front-- oh, no.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: No?
We'll pass it around.
SPEAKER: We can place it at
the front after it's complete.
It's beautiful.
Michelle and I were
talking before,
and we were saying
that no matter what
you do, as long as you have
edible flowers on the plate,
it's going to be pretty.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: That's true.
SPEAKER: And people will eat it.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
And we put those out.
You guys can just pick
them for your tacos
later, or for your
salads, as you want.
All right, so some
beautiful sumac on top.
And this I am going to
sprinkle all around the plate.
And I just want to say--
this is more along the
lines of my second book,
but it's relevant here--
I believe that there is
an issue with the tyranny
of black pepper--
black pepper as the
ubiquitous seasoning.
And I'm in my second
trimester right now.
When I was in my
first trimester,
I found it vile and I was
also having trouble cooking.
And I couldn't eat anywhere,
because black pepper
was in everything.
I'd go somewhere and
it was in the hummus.
I'm like, why does black
pepper need to be in hummus?
Just everywhere--
it was in my taco.
It was out everything.
And there are so many
beautiful spices out there.
Watercress stands in
for black pepper here,
and it has that element to it.
And then something like sumac.
You don't need to put
black pepper on everything.
I've been saying this
for years, but now
I really feel strongly about it.
I'm going to go on a crusade.
I'm going to write
an article and just--
and then the black
pepper association's
going to come after me.
SPEAKER: It could be
your third cookbook--
"The Black
Pepper-less Cookbook."
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: The
pepper-less cookbook.
All right, this guy's done.
All right, even if
you couldn't see,
I just want you-- yeah, so
if I had been able to-- oh,
do you think it'll take it?
SPEAKER: I think so.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So the screen can show.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Oh, that's it.
OK, so here.
I'll put it up here for now.
And then I'm going to
get my board clean.
Let's see.
SPEAKER: So I have a quick
question for you, Michelle.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Yes.
SPEAKER: A lot of your
vegetables and fruits
come from the farmer's
market, obviously.
And I know for myself, sometimes
when I go to farmer's market,
especially if it's
not in my hometown,
it's hard to navigate
them because there's so
many different choices
and stalls and things
that I don't
understand what they
are because they look like
foreign aliens to me sometimes.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Like kohlrabi.
SPEAKER: Like kohlrabi,
yes, absolutely.
That's definitely the alien.
So do you have any
resources or suggestions
of how we navigate
that so that we
can get more comfortable
with shopping
within a farmer's market?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Yeah.
Well, my cookbook's a resource.
SPEAKER: Well, there you go.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Wow, I've
got good at saying that.
I used to be super
uncomfortable saying that.
So here's how I approach
the farmer's market--
because you can't
go with a list.
That's the hard part for people.
Can you pass me a paper towel
for this watermelon juice?
So you can't go
with a list, right?
Because you have no
idea, really, what's
going to be there.
There's a few dependable things.
So I do a lap.
Go get yourself a cup of
coffee if that's your thing,
and then just
leisurely walk around
and take in what's there.
And then what I do
is I bring a sketch--
I have a little notebook, like
a Moleskine or something--
and I write down the
things that excited me.
Just really quickly, just messy.
usually at the top.
This is what a chef
would do, basically.
And then you can
just say, oh, OK.
The cilantro blossoms
looked really good,
and so did the watermelon.
And I saw those
Armenian cucumbers.
I've been wanting
to try one of those.
And like, OK, it kind
of could come together
in a bit of a Middle
Eastern salad.
I have some Feta at home.
And you just sketch--
in your mind, even, or
you can do it on paper--
what you want.
And you have a shopping list.
It can happen that way.
So I think the lap
is really important.
And then the people
who work at farm stands
are generally pretty
knowledgeable.
Even if they can only
give you one thing to do--
one thing to do with--
the one that I hear a lot
about is the fig leaves.
Has anyone seen fig
leaves, or have a fig tree,
or your neighbor has a fig tree?
So farmers usually--
at the farm stand,
when I hear people ask about
the fig leaves because they're
beautiful, they smell amazing.
I brought some smoked fig
leaves from last year.
We can pass these around.
You can smell them.
I smoked them.
I bought them fresh.
And I just noticed that people--
the farmer would
say, well, you can
wrap fish in them-- which
is a wonderful thing
to do with fig leaves.
It's delicious.
And the fig leaves impart
a coconut-like flavor
to your fish.
You can wrap cheese
in them, as well.
But that was the only thing
that everyone was being told.
And I'm like, well, there's
obviously a lot more
that you can do with these.
And I'm going to start playing.
So I dried them, made
spiced ones out of them,
I smoked them, I made
sugar, that sugar
went into a shortbread.
So I would say, have one
thing to do with them.
Ask one thing to do with them.
Go home, and then play.
Just play a little bit.
But the lap-- the lap is really
important, that initial lap.
AUDIENCE: What do
you smoke them in?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: You can
build a little home smoker.
I have a little ceramic
Japanese thing that's
meant to be a home smoker.
But in the back of
the book, I tell you
how to build a home one.
And they don't take very long to
get some smoke and get brittle.
It happens pretty quickly.
OK, any questions on this
recipe before I move on?
So the next thing we're going to
do is the collard green tacos.
And this is going to
definitely be a TV scenario,
because these greens take
about 30 minutes to cook.
So I'm going to get
this pan going over
medium-high heat back here.
All right, so I'm all
about using different fats
in the kitchen, and I love
pork fat and bacon fat,
and you could definitely
use that to cook
these collard greens.
For this dish, I wouldn't
necessarily love olive oil.
I also recommend coconut oil.
We have some
coconut butter here,
which gives you the flavor
and nutritional properties
of coconut oil, but
it won't quite cook.
So I'm going to
combine some canola
oil with the coconut oil.
Get that melting.
OK, it's hot.
We have some serrano chilies.
Those are going to be
for garnish, though.
So when you cooked
your collard greens,
did you throw in
the chile de arbol?
Yeah, so I don't have
one up here to show you,
but there's a chili that I use
in my kitchen every single day,
and it is called
chile de arbol, which
just means chile of the tree.
I don't know why
it has that name,
but it's the actual
name of the chili.
And you always find them dry.
And I use them--
again, I like to tell
people because they
understand-- like a bayleaf.
So I'll heat up my cooking oil--
or fat, whatever it is--
and I add my chile de arbol.
And depending on how much heat
I want, I can remove it quickly.
It'll just add a
little bit of heat.
Or I can leave it in
while I cook my greens
and then remove it at the end.
And make sure you
remove it at the end.
And what that does
is it just adds--
depending on your chiles and
how long you leave it in,
it adds a kind of pervasive
heat, a gentle heat.
Versus adding a bunch of
chili flakes, which can
be a little bit overpowering.
Or if you added--
I don't like chili powder.
Personally, I think it's
always tastes stale.
So this is a really fresh,
fragrant chile to use.
And they stay good in the
cupboard for a long time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
I keep it whole.
You can break it in half, but
you're going to get more heat.
So you can determine
how much heat you want.
And when I need
chili flakes, I take
my whole chile de arbols and
I put them in a spice grinder
and I grind them myself, because
so many of the chilies that you
buy--
they're stale.
They've been exposed
to the light too long,
and they don't have a
lot of their flavor.
Chilies have a really
complex flavor.
They're not just
heat they're floral.
Some are earthy.
You get all these
flavors from them.
But once they've been
powdered, you lose that.
I'm going to turn this
up just a little bit.
OK.
So that's it.
I would just cook this with
some oil, salt, and chile.
Some I'm going to
just put these in.
And these will
wilt down by half.
And how long you have
to cook collard greens
depends on how thinly you cut
them and how young they are.
If you buy little,
baby collard greens
they can cook pretty quickly.
Some of the really--
if you get a big bunch,
they can take up to an hour.
So with recipes, you have
to think about your produce
and go with that.
Pay attention to that.
So while those are cooking,
I'm going to throw together
a tomatillo salsa.
I'm going to pass
around a tomatillo.
So these three little guys come
into season about a month ago,
maybe a little bit more.
And they last all the
way through October.
And you can look under that
little paper-like lantern
and you'll see the
green tomatillo.
They're actually ripe
when they're yellow,
but we use them primarily
when they're green.
And you can roast them, and
that gives them great flavor;
grill them; or use them raw.
When you use them raw-- this
is how easy this salsa is.
Tomatillos just quartered--
so you remove the husk.
You rinse them.
They go in.
Add some salt.
Some chopped chile.
So those collard
greens are spicy.
I'm going to add just a
little bit of chopped chile.
If I have time, I'll show you
my favorite way to cut a chile,
but only if we have
time, we'll see.
And some garlic
and some cilantro.
And when I'm using cilantro--
I use herbs all the time.
And oftentimes, I pick them--
like I did for the
salad-- where you just
get these little whole
leaves like this.
Because I think they
should be an ingredient.
I don't think they
should just be a garnish.
But for something like
this, I just take my knife
and I just shear off
some leaves quickly.
Yeah, see-- sharp
knife makes cooking
very efficient and safe.
And then I form them
into a bit of a bundle
and then just slice
them like that,
and then they go straight in.
I'm going to do a little bit
of-- just a tiny bit of lime
in this.
And we're just
going to puree this.
I don't need a lot
of lime in this,
because lime is practically dry.
All right.
[FOOD PROCESSOR WHIRRING]
I like them better than
tomatoes and salsa.
That's just me.
AUDIENCE: For cilantro, you
[INAUDIBLE] cut it really fine
versus putting it in whole
in the food processor?
Oh, Oh, you need to
chop it up a little bit.
You can't put it
in whole, because I
want this to remain coarse.
And if I put my
cilantro in whole,
by the time the
cilantro gets chopped,
basically, it'll be pureed.
And I want this to be
a little bit coarse.
This is what we're going
for, where there's still
some texture to the tomatillos.
Good question.
[FOOD PROCESSOR WHIRRING]
And again, if you wanted
a deeper, smokier flavor,
you could chargrill these--
even just on a cast iron
pan on your stovetop.
You could get some char on the
tomatillos and then do that.
I think I just got
cilantro on my glasses.
It's OK.
SPEAKER: How long are
tomatillos in season for?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I think
around here, through October.
SPEAKER: OK.
Make a lot and can it.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: One of my
favorite recipes in the book
is a green fish stew
that uses tomatillos.
Love it so much.
All right, and
that is your salsa.
The trick-- I'm
sure some of you,
if you've taken classes here,
you've probably seen this.
You just put your finger
in the bottom of the bowl,
and then it doesn't fall out.
And then I would let this
sit for about 20 minutes,
and then taste and add more
salt before serving it.
I'm sure it needs some
more salt. Let the flavors
meld a little bit
before you serve it.
How are we on time?
SPEAKER: Good, 20 minutes.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Good.
Great.
I love going on tangents.
And then I never know--
SPEAKER: I do, too.
This works well.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: All right,
let's get this board wiped off.
So what I'm going
to show you now
is how I would compose one
of these collard green tacos.
And I'm going to show
you-- you know what?
Since we have a
little extra time,
I'm going to show
you just a very--
because I taught my
skills once a month
for four years at
least, and I've noticed
people don't know how
to get into a chile.
So I'm just going to
show you real fast.
So the seeds run
down the middle.
This is a huge one.
This will be easy.
Sometimes when you get
the little serranos,
they're really hard.
But the seeds run
down the middle,
and they contain
most of the heat.
So I like to cut
around the seeds.
So I hold my chile
lengthwise, and I just cut off
the flesh of the pepper around.
So I just rotate the pepper
and go around the seeds
so the seeds are still
contained right there.
Now, this you can--
in a blender, if you were
making a super-pureed salsa,
you could just remove the
stem and put this in there
and get a spicy salsa.
So this has a use if you
want to use it for that.
Then if you wanted a fine dice,
I would take these, and I go--
so the shiny skin-side down.
The knife will cut much more
easily through the dull side.
And I cut little matchsticks
with my fingers tucked under.
So then you get
these matchsticks.
Then you can take those and
line up maybe four of them,
and then slice
those into a dice.
And that's just a really
fast way to get into a chile.
So I just wanted
to show you that,
because I get lots of
people who look at a chile
and they just start slicing
it, and I don't know.
A lot of people know how to
cut an onion because that's
demo'd so often, but
something like a chile
just gets forgotten.
OK, so to heat up
some tortillas--
I'm going to put a
skillet on medium-low--
or what I think is
medium-low on this.
So I have a little stack--
these super tiny,
really cute tortillas.
So if you're heating up
tortillas for a taco--
again, I love
teaching people how
to cook for more
than just one person.
So let's say you're
cooking for six people,
and you want to heat
up-- or even just three
people-- you want to heat up
a stack of little tortillas.
Can you guys see this?
Here, I'll even.
Here's an easy way to do it.
So you put one tortilla
down in the pan.
This might take it a second.
Maybe I'll cheat and
move the collard greens
and use this back guy,
because it's already hot.
OK, so you put one down.
And that side's
going to heat up, OK?
I'm so used to using flame.
With induction, like,
what's happening?
I can't see it.
SPEAKER: It's like a spaceship.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: And so,
OK, so that side gets warm.
And then you flip it over, and
you add your next cold tortilla
to the hot side.
And then so then the other--
so OK.
This guy's in the
pan-- for those of you
that can't see the skillet.
This guy's in the pan.
He's hot.
I flip him over.
I add my cold tortilla.
This side's heating up.
I flip this over.
I add another cold tortilla.
This side gets hot.
I flip it over.
I add another cold
tortilla, right?
And then if you're
taking them to the table
to serve them, wrap them in--
I do parchment and then foil,
because once you heat them up,
if you don't wrap them
or serve them right away,
they get rubbery.
There we go.
Flip them.
Add that one.
Let that go.
So I'm going to heat
up a few, and I'm
going to compose a taco.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the parchment
[INAUDIBLE] let it steam?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I
just do that because I'm
weird about my own foil.
That's just one of my things.
I don't like aluminum
foil on my food.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: You
see too many times--
when you cook a lot on
aluminum pans, aluminum racks--
you see it come
off on food a lot.
It's not going to come off on
tortillas, because they have
nothing acidic in them, really.
Well, they do, but it's not
going to come off on tortillas.
But when you see it come off
on things like baked goods--
I had a chef cooking a private
dinner at my cooking school,
and the best way-- well,
here's another little side tip.
See, I love these tangents,
because you get little tips.
If you want to get really
crispy skin on your chicken,
you salt it the night before.
But you don't wrap
it in Tupperware
or put it in a baggie.
You put it on a cooling rack
set on top of a sheet pan
so that evaporation can happen.
But he was just doing
chicken breasts,
and he used an
aluminum drying rack.
And when he got in
the next morning,
the chicken was gray
from the aluminum.
Anything that's reactive,
I'm just super careful with.
If that makes any sense.
So there's just those little
stories where I'm just like,
OK, I'm just going to always
protect my food from anything
that's going to react with it.
All right, I'm going to get
my composition ingredients up
here.
So Chef Dee Dee and her
team mashed some avocado.
We have some sour
cream, or creme fraiche.
We have cilantro blossoms, which
you can also put on that salad.
Some thinly sliced green onion.
Some-- I love radishes on tacos,
just thinly sliced radishes.
They've got that peppery element
without the black pepper.
Move this out of the way.
Some lime and some cilantro.
I'm going to use the
cilantro blossoms,
and I'm going to leave that off.
All right, so does everyone
understand the taco things?
I'm going to turn this off.
How to heat the tortillas.
All right, I think that's good.
I think you know
what you're doing.
All right, so I'm going
to take two of these.
And I like to do
avocado down first,
because it creates a bit of a
glue for the other ingredients.
And I have some cooked
beans back here.
You could use pinto,
black-- really any bean
that you'd like.
SPEAKER: Do you recommend
cooking your own beans
if you have the time?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I don't know.
I'm relaxed on the bean thing.
I mean, well, if you
really want to know--
SPEAKER: We do.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I
have a Colombian bean
pot which is made of clay.
I eat a lot of beans.
And beans cooked
in clay do taste
different than any
bean you've ever had.
And I'm not just saying that.
Because honestly,
between this and canned--
you jazz it up with some chili
and some salt, you're OK.
It's going to taste delicious.
And honestly, if
canned beans enable
you to cook at home
versus eat out,
buy canned beans by all means.
But I had this
Colombian bean pot.
It's huge, and I cook
a big batch of beans.
And you can freeze them.
They freeze really well.
But the clay imparts
this unbelievable flavor
to the beans.
And I grew up-- like I said,
my family is from the South,
and they also cooked
beans in clay.
And baked beans were
baked in a bean pot.
It was a southern bean pot,
it's a different shape.
And they baked them in clay.
It's a thing-- beans and clay.
AUDIENCE: It's totally different
than a [INAUDIBLE] or something
else with the glaze?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Right.
No glaze.
AUDIENCE: How do you clean it?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: You
clean it carefully.
And you just don't want to use
an abrasive sponge or anything,
but you can still
use a little soap.
You would never put
it in the dishwasher.
It would crack in
the dishwasher.
You just have to be careful
about temperature differences.
It will crack.
But I've been using
mine for years.
I've never had a problem.
AUDIENCE: So the
surface is porous?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Huh?
AUDIENCE: The surface
of the clay is porous.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Sorry,
I can't understand.
AUDIENCE: Porous.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Porous-- it's
porous Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's
porous.
But people have been cooking
in clay for a long time.
I did a pilot for
the Cooking Channel.
The whole episode was
about cooking with clay.
I mean, I geek out
on the clay thing.
I really love it.
There's a great shop
in Sonoma called Bram--
B-R-A-M. Bram is the name
of an Egyptian clay pot.
That's also in the book.
And that shop has clay
from all over the world.
And it's just a cool shop, and
it's run by Ash and Shelley.
And Ash is this guy who will
just fill you with information
and maybe give you
vegetables from his garden.
You guys should field
trip up to Bram in Sonoma,
and then go shopping.
And then go to El
Molino Central,
which is the best Mexican
food in the Bay Area--
in my opinion.
Bay Area-- it's
Boyes Hot Springs.
I don't know if
that's the Bay Area.
It's within two hours.
But it's a field trip.
It's a fun day.
AUDIENCE: What was it called?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
El Molino Central.
Who's been to the Ferry
market on Saturday mornings--
the Ferry building?
You guys know Primavera?
El Molino's the
restaurant of Primavera.
So if you've had a
Primavera fish taco,
you know what I'm talking about.
They're delicious.
OK, back to these poor tacos
that have been abandoned.
Some collard greens
on top of the beans.
And you don't want
to overstuff these,
but you want them
to be generous.
But overstuffed are
too hard to eat.
And then whatever you want.
If you want some extra chile,
you can do some of the chile.
A little bit of creme
fraiche, a few radishes.
So when you do
radishes for tacos,
though, they need
to be paper thin.
So either a really sharp
knife or a mandoline--
if you feel
comfortable using one.
It's a great tool for
efficiency, as well.
I don't care that much
about efficiency in general,
but I understand that people
who don't cook for a living--
they need it to be efficient.
And so I love giving
those tips when I can,
OK, and then some
cilantro flowers,
which totally change the
game on how pretty a taco is.
SPEAKER: Flowers make
everything beautiful.
Look at that!
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Then
you crack open a beer.
OK, so there's some
little vegetarian tacos.
And that's it.
SPEAKER: Lovely.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Oh, no!
That's not it.
SPEAKER: The salsa.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I'm
talking about aluminum
and forgot all about
the tomatillo salsa.
This salsa, by the way, I
love it with fried eggs.
I eat a lot of eggs, too.
So fried eggs, tomatillos.
It's good on chicken.
It's good on grilled corn.
You can put it on sandwiches--
mayo and then a little
bit of tomatillo salsa.
Some turkey, some
pickled jalapenos.
SPEAKER: That's great.
Those both look amazing.
So I think we're going to
open it up to some questions.
I'm sure you guys have a couple.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Anything.
SPEAKER: Anything.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Cooking-related.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
forage them?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
No, I don't forage.
So purslane in San
Francisco, which
is primarily where I shop-- so
definitely farmer's markets.
But even a co-op market like
Rainbow Grocery sells purslane.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Oh, I don't know
if I've had that experience.
I've seen the one in Rainbow.
It's in little bundles.
It's still small.
I mean, it grows
long and spindly,
and it also grows
short and squat.
If you've seen a
flavor difference,
it could be just where it is
in the season and the soil.
But--
AUDIENCE: What about nettles?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Nettles
I see everywhere now.
I've even seen those
at big grocery stores.
God, I would not want
to forage for nettles.
My first experience with
nettles was in Wales hiking,
and I had no idea
what they were.
That was not a good experience.
But yeah, I'm
seeing that around.
Something like burdock
I would seek out.
Although I have seen
it in Whole Foods,
I would seek it out
from a Japanese market
if you can find--
it's fun, too, if you want
to seek something out.
It's an adventure to go
find this cool thing.
I don't know if it's
still a good resource--
I haven't used it in years--
but Chowhound is
a site that used
to have forums where
people would say,
has anyone found burdock
in Mountain View?
And then people
would respond and say
where they had found it.
So that's one way you
could maybe seek it out.
But definitely farmer's markets.
And ask farmers if they grow.
Sometimes, too, when a
farmer hears enough requests,
they will start growing it.
The reason we grow so much
Romaine in this country
is not because it's good for
the earth to grow mostly Romaine
or because it's good for
us or because Romaine
is the best-- although I
like it in a lot of things.
It's because it's what
they think will sell.
So if somebody thinks that
something else will sell,
they'll start growing it.
Farmers right now are
sitting on cilantro blossoms.
They don't know they
have a market for them
until people start
asking for them.
So once people start saying,
hey, I have this cookbook,
or I saw on the Washington
Post about cilantro blossoms,
do you have any?
They're like, yeah.
I'll bring some next week.
And then they get to
make money off that, too.
But as far as the weeds
in the back of the book--
things like lamb's quarter--
even though it grows
wild and it is found--
most people forage it--
you can grow it.
There's a farmer at
the Ferry building
who grows lamb's quarter.
I bought a 2 pound
bag of it last week
and made a lamb and
lamb's quarter filo
pie with a Turkish
spice blend mixed in.
And baked it and put
some bee pollen on top.
It was really good.
AUDIENCE: You
should've brought some.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Should
have brought some.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
I should have.
I'm not going to be
able to eat all of it.
That would have been weird.
I think I would have gotten in
trouble if I just passed out
a homemade filo pie,
already a piece missing.
SPEAKER: It would
have been fine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Yeah, I think anywhere
that buys farm direct--
a grocery store that buys farm
direct-- and that's increasing.
Do you guys have Good
Eggs delivery down here?
Good Eggs-- it's a
grocery delivery company
in San Francisco.
They have things
like cilantro flowers
and shiso and some other things.
I think you'll see
this more and more,
which is why I think
this book was timely.
More and more people want a
greater diversity of food.
They're eating it
in restaurants.
They're eating nettles
on their pizza, right?
And they're like, I
want some nettles.
And so those things are going to
start showing up more and more.
Hopefully-- because it
is good for us and it is
good for the soil to not have
just one crop growing in it.
SPEAKER: And if
you have something
that I've found that you
really, really want and you
go to a specialty store,
they can order it for you
as long as it's in season.
They might not just
have a big ask for it.
But you can find it,
usually, if you ask.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Totally.
Bi-Rite Market in
San Francisco--
if you went in and you said,
I want some flowering dill,
they'll say, OK, I'll
reach out to my farmers
and see if I can find something.
For sure.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Does anyone else
have any more questions?
It'll be that funky thing
where I ask it back.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
What did you guys think
about the-- did it make it
around, the smoked fig leaves?
What did you guys think?
SPEAKER: Where did that end up?
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
It's intoxicating.
And this is a year old.
This is from last year.
So good.
So I make a sugar out of
this and make shortbread.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Do you--
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: I
think they're too thick.
I've never tried that.
Even if you steamed
them first, maybe.
But they're better-- and
they're a strong flavor.
Grape leaves aren't
a strong flavor,
but fig leaves are a
really strong flavor.
I like them more--
they infuse something or they're
powdered into a spice blend
or to sugar.
But to eat them like a
dolma would be pretty--
when you wrap fish in
them, you unwrap the fish
and eat the fish.
And it's imparted its
flavor to the fish.
So I think somebody like
dolma, they'd be too strong.
Well, 18 Reasons was
the cooking school.
It's on 18th street
in the Mission.
I left as the program
director in December.
But I'm going to
be teaching there--
I'm blanking on the date--
maybe the 15th of September
I'm teaching there?
So I'm still going to
keep teaching there.
It's a wonderful cooking school.
It's for home cooks only.
It's actually a
nonprofit organization.
So all the money that they
make in that little 18th street
event space funds
free cooking classes
all over the Bay Area in
low income communities.
So if you live in the city
or if you want something
to do out one night,
it's a fun place to go.
All sorts of cooking classes.
Quirky stuff, too, like
breakfasts of Southeast Asia,
and I'm teaching
flavors of Azerbaijan.
Yep.
My best friend growing
up was from Baku,
and her family
got asylum outside
of Nashville, Tennessee.
And she lived walking
distance from my house.
And I grew up around food.
I mean, again-- southern
family, lots of cooking.
But I mean the food
that her-- so she
lived with her mother, her
father, her grandparents,
their crazy husky
named [? Kazbek ?] who
did not understand any
English, And her brother.
And there was so much
food in that house.
I mean, her
grandmother just cooked
all day-- made fresh bread.
Every dinner was just a feast.
You come near the kitchen
and they're feeding you.
And that's still the
food that I crave,
and it's still how I cook.
And it's a mix of-- because
all these places that have--
sort of like Sicilian food.
When you have an area
that has been conquered
by so many different people,
the food becomes fascinating.
So Azerbaijan has
been-- you have
Russian influence, Armenian
influence, Persian influence,
Turkish influence.
The food is just
ridiculously good.
So I'm teaching a class on that.
SPEAKER: So thank you
so much for showing
us these great recipes.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE: Yeah,
thank you for having me.
SPEAKER: I'm really excited
to hear back from you guys
about all the great
stuff that you
do with all the amazing
recipes you have.
MICHELLE MCKENZIE:
Yeah, thank you.
SPEAKER: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]